-Making their U.S. TV debut
performing "Scratchcard Lanyard"
from their album "New Long Leg,"
please welcome Dry Cleaning!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
-♪ Many years have passed
but you're still charming ♪
♪ Rose falling
and exploding ♪
♪ And you can't save the world
on your own ♪
♪ I guess ♪
♪ Don't send me it ♪
♪ You keep it ♪
♪♪
♪ Weak arms,
can't open the door ♪
♪ Kung fu council ♪
♪ It'll be okay, I just need to
be weird and hide for a bit ♪
♪ And eat an old sandwich
from my bag ♪
♪ I've come here to make
a ceramic shoe ♪
♪ And I've come to smash
what you made ♪
♪ I've come to learn
how to mingle ♪
how to dance ♪
♪ I've come to join
your knitting circle ♪
♪ I've come to hand-weave
my own bunk bed ladder ♪
♪ In a few short sessions ♪
♪ It's a Tokyo bouncy ball ♪
♪ It's an Oslo bouncy ball ♪
♪ It's a Rio de Janeiro
bouncy ball ♪
♪ Filter, I love these
mighty oaks, don't you? ♪
♪ Do everything
and feel nothing ♪
♪ Wristband, theme park,
scratch card, lanyard ♪
♪ Do everything
and feel nothing ♪
♪ Pat dad on the head ♪
♪ Alright you big loudmouth ♪
♪ And thanks very much
for the Twix ♪
♪ I think of myself
as a hearty banana ♪
♪ With that waxy surface ♪
♪ And the small
delicate flowers ♪
♪ A woman in aviators
firing a bazooka ♪
♪ I've come here to make
a ceramic shoe ♪
♪ And I've come to smash
what you made ♪
♪ I've come to learn
how to mingle ♪
how to dance ♪
♪ I've come to join
the knitting circle ♪
♪ That's just child chat ♪
♪ Why don't you want
oven chips now? ♪
♪ It's a Tokyo bouncy ball ♪
♪ It's an Oslo bouncy ball ♪
♪ It's a Rio de Janeiro
bouncy ball ♪
♪ Filter, I love these
mighty oaks, don't you? ♪
♪ Do everything
and feel nothing ♪
♪ Wristband, theme park,
scratch card, lanyard ♪
♪ Do everything
and feel nothing ♪
♪♪
♪ You seem really together ♪
♪ You've got a new coat ♪
♪ New hair ♪
♪ Well, I'll tell you
one thing ♪
♪ You've got it coming ♪
♪ One day,
you're gonna get it ♪
♪ Ha ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]